uh i love gals i really i'm a i'm a gal
kind of fella you know what i mean
what i mean is i love gabbing with gals
gabbing like gals and i thought it would
be fun to gab with one of my absolute
favorite gals alison williams she plays
marnie on the show girls so she is a
girl but she's also a gal
and i thought it would be fun to gab
with her
because i love gabbing
with let's just run the clip
can i tell you somebody asked me what
the pete home show was about recently i
always like to describe it i said it's
about four young girls living in
manhattan and brooklyn trying to figure
it out what did they say it's not for me
they said great because they had no idea
who i was
there was there's a couple girls on the
couch
so i don't really eat this stuff but
it's really good
i only eat this kind of stuff really you
don't know that because i don't have a
podcast
you listen to my podcast i do
religiously you know a lot about me yeah
i do but these people don't know a lot
about me can you tell them anything
and tell them do you know about me
really yeah um he freely provides the
information of his therapist yup what's
his name doctor gary penn dr gary pence
available it's available your mom is too
supportive your dad is not supportive
enough
this is awesome you say how old was i
when i lost my virginity oh it was three
six pumps is that right
how many pumps are there six pumps six
pumps you were uh eight uh twenty one
twenty one twenty one uh you were
married for six years yep um very good
good or creepy we'll decide at the end
oh why did we get divorced
she had an affair
with a man named oh i don't know that
rocco but you do hope she sees all the
comments for yourself so if you're
watching he's doing so
well whoops
would you like me more if i talked in a
boston accent
yeah boston accent i kind of said boston
boston boston boston boston it's wider
wider wider wider chowder give me a give
me a box of chowder
box
there's a leaking crab all right give me
a box of chowder to go my mother's sick
and she wants to box the chicken [ __ ]
cranky my mother's sick
she's like
look she's got dimension she asks for a
box of chowder and if i don't bring a
box don't you yell at me put it in a box
i don't give a [ __ ] what kind of box but
sir it'll fall out at the bottom thank
you
here's a question for you mm-hmm
ugh men right
ugh
right
i was terrible at answering that there
you were i think i was ready yeah here's
a question for you
men right